[Music]
all right so John and I are going to
split ours uh up we're going to talk to
you a little bit about uh biocurity like
you heard um Dr Speer talk we have to
step up our biocurity so we really got
to think about the things we're going to
do and how we're going to uh how we're
going to move forward so I'm sure
everybody has been doing some thinking
on some of the things that you know what
are we going to do what what's that
Shield going to be that we're going to
do on our Farms to really protect us
from biocurity and you know when it
comes down it comes down to all of you
and me we're The Growers we're the ones
that make the decision on who comes on
our Farms if we don't stop it nobody
else is so there might be some
unpleasant um situations but we need to
deal with those certainly very important
so when we're talking about our plan we
need to think about really the three
things our production site what are the
things that we can do in our production
site the people coming in and then also
um equipment and vehicles so let's talk
about our production site what are the
some of the things that we can do Dr spe
talked about this line this dirty line
and this clean line what are some of the
things anybody got any ideas of some of
the things we can
do change your foot change your Footwear
right Tina so we can think about from
each house a lot of people have Annie
rooms some of some people don't have
Annie rooms we can put separate shoes
from house to house we can put on the
little slipon
booties uh from house to house we've got
the plastic ones uh also so another
thing that um we have done on our farm
is trying to think of some of the things
that we carry in and out we're carrying
in and out
buckets we're carrying I have chicken
picker uppers I call them the regets so
we shouldn't be carrying those in and
out so we bought I took two buckets per
house cleaned them all up disinfected
them we lose like a 10% um bleach
solution clean them up cleaned up our
chicken picker uppers we put up little
hooks in our houses they those buckets
and those chicken picker up or stay in
those houses they're dedicated to that
so we're picking up chickens and you
know you're driving down with your golf
cart or your Gator your tractor whatever
you sit one bucket outside the door but
when so when you're dumping your dead
chickens out
you can you're not taking that bucket
outside don't let it touch anything
outside but you're keeping that kind of
that clean and dirty line so I think
it's just those type of things that we
really need to think about to to take it
to that that certainly to that next uh
level
people my gosh my mother comes over you
know she drives right down the bar I'm
like Mom you cannot drive down to the
barn she's bringing us lunch but you
know call us you know we'll we'll come
up but you know it's just this
re-education of things that we just
really don't don't think about the
people that come on our farm I had a um
grower call me last week and said Jenny
I was home for the day and you know she
works off the farm she say the electric
person came up from the electric company
to read the meter you know farmer next
door has you know grows for amch one
grows for mount air one grows for Allen
one grows for Purdue so um they didn't
have the smart meters yet so we worked
uh don't you know most of you know that
I sit on the DPI board also so we d a
letter Bill worked on John and I worked
on to send out to the Allied Industries
to you know let them know there's you
know there's this threat of Avan
influenza we've got to do everything we
can if you got to go to a farm don't
drive down to the production area put on
your booties you got to go read the
meter go read the meter walk back to the
truck throw the booties away there so I
think those will just be the simple
things and we have to be that first um
line of defense I just put on our for
you between the house and the production
area I just turned up some orange um
vegetable baskets trying to think now
what could I do to stop people and lo
and behold I got a phone call from my
biocurity sign that had a phone number
on it it was a trash man and I forgot
because we had told him that we were
going to move our trash dumpster up up
to the house I really don't want it up
to the house cuz it's ugly and I when I
pull up my Lane I like the way that it
looks so I said well can you he comes
back next week I said not this week but
next week we'll move it up to the house
so that so just those little things that
you you know you don't think about so
think about those things and then um
equipment uh
Vehicles think about it John's going to
talk a little bit about you know washing
equipment um when we talk about
equipment one of the most important uh
pieces we have what's
this how many germs do you think are on
this thing where does it go it goes
everywhere with us how many people Tak
in the chicken house with
them so you might want to think about
while you're washing your hands before
you go in the chicken house keep some
disinfectant wipes clean your cell phone
or leave it don't take it in and clean
it when you get done there's just these
little things that we really just really
don't uh think about so these are really
the absolute things that we just need to
think about and the things that we do uh
on our Farms no back yard poultry I
think we all know that but we just need
to say it and let everybody know if you
have any neighbors that have backyard
poultry the Maryland Department of a has
sent out the poultry premise
registration just make sure that
everybody gets registered so if there is
an outbreak that everybody will
know uh so I mean we see backyard
poultry everywhere you know on Route 213
there's somebody that has backyard
poultry and they're on the road half of
the time I have a heart attack when I
drive past them I have to check to make
sure they are registered
um but no pet birds the same you know
the same thing I think we all we all
know a lot of this Dina talked about you
know dedicated Footwear I don't care who
comes on your farm they either put
plastic boots on or they have dedicated
Footwear you'll see my grandson a little
while he has dedicated Footwear when he
comes stays right in the we have call it
the man cave that we put our boots on
but it's it's a cheap thing that we can
do for something that can devastate our
industry and devastate each one of us
most of us have mortgage payments and um
things that we need to pay for so and if
you're worried uh somebody's going to
wear them off paint them pink paint them
purple I don't care do something so
someone's not going to take them um off
the
farm uh we talked about this um
unauthorized visitors you know when
we're not on our farm we really don't
know who's coming up there we really
don't if you anything you can do to keep
unauthorized visitors and it's hard
because we got feed trucks you know
coming on our farm we've got people um
delivering propane so but like I said
it's our job you see that propane coming
truck coming up and they haven't
disinfected put a little pump up sprayer
out there I think most of us now have
probably mailboxes up John's going to
talk about those you know put a little
pump up sprayer out there can hurt so
make sure that you do have all the
personal uh protective equipment John
and I have uh you know the coveralls
anybody that's coming up you can put
them in your
mailbox uh there's all kinds of foot
oops
Footwear we've got the little cloth
things we have little cloth footies we
have the plastic ones we have a hair net
or headnet also disinfectant wipes oh
and then our just our hand hand
sanitizer so a lot of things don't
forget to get your sign tonight put your
phone number on there it worked worked
for me just just last week so just some
things uh really to think
about uh things are going to break down
and we're going to have to call one of
the poultry stores I call them you know
to come fix things so and they're all
all are certainly aware but that's our
job to check on them you know where you
going to make them Park make sure that
they've got their protective equipment
on make sure you have a place for them
to dispose of it when they come on to
your
farm mortal oh
mortality we've got to be doing a good
job of composting that's certainly very
important because if we don't do a good
job of composting then we get all these
little critters
and we don't need that because that they
just spread they just spread disease so
some other things to think about educate
your employees educate your families
people that have um employees same thing
you know they need dedicated Footwear
dedicated coveralls or clothing
something that they they leave on your
farm they put it on when they get there
between that dirty and clean line think
about you know those kind of things
washing your hands just very simple
basic things we all talk about not the
flu you know and colds more you wash
your hands certainly the better off
you'll be so again just back to those
absolute things no backyard poultry
we've got to have dedicated clothes
dedicated Footwear no unauthorized
visitors um personal protective clothing
you can buy this I mean all this I'm
sure you can get it on Amazon you can go
to the you know I call G&M sales and
they send it to me that works uh very
well and then um also um do a good job
with your
composting so without these things you
really don't have a biocurity plan and
you need to talk to talk to your family
about it talk to your partner about it
you know just different things that we
really don't think about oops okay all
right so now we're going to go through
this we're getting late so I'll try and
go through this quickly how's that if
you have questions just raise your hand
I'll slow down okay some factors to
consider you all know where your Farms
are located there's things you need to
be aware of are you located next to a
big pond well if you build a new Farm
you have a storm Runner storm water pond
so we have that we're kind of making
things a little harder for Farmers but
we want to be aware we wear an area
where there's a lot of water foul who
lives next to our farm we need to know
who our neighbors are do they have
poultry do they have backyard poultry
are we located next to a big road I mean
there was a farm I saw put on a for Road
the other day and I I drive by I can see
all the feathers from the live Hall
trucks already sucked up into the cool
cells so we want to make sure we do it
we can to keep our farm safe and if you
have any of those things we have to do a
little more but things we recommend
visitor logs visitor logs are great
because then we know if there's anything
happens who was on your farm we can
start tracing these diseases and find
out who we need to really worry about or
if somebody brought it on we can start
looking and see where this disease went
thing about visitor logs is we put them
in a mailbox love mailboxes go buy one
of the biggest ones you can because then
there's lots of room for
spiders just
joking then you can take and stuff some
uh personal protective wear in there you
know we can put in some cover all some
boots and all that that way if anybody's
coming on your farm and you aren't there
you can tell them the clothing is there
for them and tell them where it's at and
these are real easy way to put it on or
if you have somebody show up you know
where it is it's right there at the
entrance to your farm so it makes it
real simple to do the other thing is put
up a
sign do sign stop disease signs no but
they stop people it's interesting we've
actually had calls lately people ask
asking why are we seeing these biocurity
signs I think that's great because that
means people are noticing that we're
worried about our birds and what we're
doing it gives us an opportunity to talk
to them about why farmers are putting
them up and what we need to do to
protect our
Birds okay at the same place if we're at
the same place we're still where we put
our mailbox up what about putting a
chain or something across the road there
to stop people from just driving on in
Jenny put up their little cones or
upside down uh vegetable baskets that's
it go get some soccer cones you can get
them at Walmart they're cheap put those
across there anything that will stop
people from driving on down that way
they're thinking uh this again if you
have all this I mean he's pulling across
the chain but his mailbox is sitting
right there so everything is right there
for anybody that comes on the farm so
he's got it all right there it's not oh
well where am I going to look where am I
going to find it this is a camera on
another farm this way anybody pulls on
their Farm they can't see it they live a
little ways away around the corner but
if I pull on their Farm it takes a
picture of me in my vehicle and it sends
it to them and they know I'm there great
thing about it you know who's on your
farm bad thing about it takes pictures
of Doe's in the middle of the night I
don't think they'd complain if it was a
big buck but they were complaining it
was a dough locks locks are very
important keep things well keep things
locked down we do have a lot of crime
going on we need to keep people out has
anybody paid attention to what happened
down in South Carolina last spring and
summer you heard about it didn't you
200,000 Birds killed somebody went in
and started playing with controllers and
everything else we want to make sure
we're doing what we can to prevent that
from happening here so lock doors lock
things
up let's see bird exclusion Dr Shiro's
talked about this a lot I just want to
add this when we Birds go out we often
leave our end doors open for days on end
and I see it all the time maybe we need
to shut them if we're not working in
there just shut the doors kick on your
minimum ventilation to keep it aired out
but we need to shut those doors cuz
Birds after about the first 2 4 hours
they're going to start going in there
those birds are possibly going to bring
some type of disease parasite or
something I'm you know Northern fomites
I've seen that happen before so we want
to make sure we keep those birds
out rodent
control again you don't want to see this
rat rats running down the rafters I had
a really cool picture I can't find it's
a rat drinking from a nipple Drinker and
it's I mean these are things you see in
chicken houses if things are not done
right now I will say we do a good job
job around here keeping our stuff out
whether you use the homemade type of of
bait stations or you buy the bait
stations we're doing a good job this is
what we want to see we want to keep our
pads clean Dr Shapiro mentioned
that um Beetle control another one we
don't think a lot about beetles can
Harbor disease and carry them from one
flock to the next so we want to make
sure we have a good Beetle control
program to try and knock those bugs
down foot baths I'm a fan of foot baths
when they're done right that foot bath
is not right you can smell it from where
I'm taking the picture this person
should have known better that's wor
you'd have been worse off stepping in
that than just going straight in the
house if you do it right they work but
remember we don't want to see this we
want to see something like well like
this see he's got a good clean foot bath
if we can get Jenny's grandson to play
in the water and clean his boots we can
train our employees and us to do it how
old four years old can understand a foot
bath so we want to make sure we do this
clean things up here's a brush remember
when we clean our shoes to get it right
we got to get that mud off or it's not
going to do any good in disinfecting so
we've got to get the debris off so we
want to make sure we clean things up one
thing we might want to do it's hard to
see in this picture but flat shoes with
no no big grooves by doing that you're
not going to get a lot of debris stuck
in the bottom of your shoe work great
except for if you step outside on ice or
brand new litter kind of get slippery so
we got to be careful
there I'm a fan of dedicated Footwear in
each house when I had a farm that's what
I did each house had its own Footwear
slip in when you go in slip it off when
you come out boots are cheap they're not
that expensive Dr Shapiro showed one way
where you sit down on a bench take your
shoes off throw your legs over the other
side of the bench put the other shoes on
just a simple change like that granted
we have a lot of houses without Andy
rooms so we need to find other things
out other ways to do it but yall are
very creative and and I'm sure you can
find ways to make these kind of systems
work foot baths whatever works for you
but you need to find a way to make it
work on your farm and then you need to
be the one that always does it so that
if you have other people that work with
you they see you doing it CU if people
will watch you and if you're not doing
it they're going to figure they don't
have
to uh hunting waterfoul again kind of
risky right now I don't know if we have
any big waterfoul hunters in here but uh
if you're going to hunt water foul take
extra precautions or maybe take a year
off uh not my place to call that but be
very
careful you laugh at that all right be
careful around convenience stores love
it this was a picture that used to have
a whole bunch of poop here but by the
time we got there the rain washed it off
so it's a picture of a nice curb but
look at this truck here pull into their
gas station he's sitting there with that
do you think that spread manure as he
drove down the road yeah do you think
it's kind of a good way to be can you
imagine what the front of that truck
looks like these are the people you're
dealing with so when you go to the store
make sure you don't take those shoes
back down this is where everybody stops
to get their coffee and donuts in the
morning you don't want to pick something
up from somebody else that went there
Again Farm dedicated
Footwear water ponds geese we need to
find ways to discourage them from coming
in I'm a fan of a young retriever
Labrador chesap doesn't matter just a
young retriever let him go out there and
Chase the heck out of them it's legal
you're not harming them so there are
some things we can do as well you can
get permission to Addle eggs where you
go out and shake their eggs up or break
their eggs you have to get permission
there are legal ways to do it there are
some ways to get permits to do
deprivation hunts but there are ways to
help lower the number of water foul
around your
farm uh bird droppings we've covered
that washing hands I know a lot of y'all
don't have places to wash your hands on
a farm I was on a farm the other day and
I said well you know we came out of the
house we're kind of dirty and they pick
this bucket off off the back of their uh
their four-wheeler and they carry this
bucket every day they go out when they
start going around fill it up with clean
soapy water you're done had a little
chlorine in there you washed up you were
done real simple didn't cost them
anything this is one of those hand
sanitizers you've seen them in a lot of
buildings you just walk by you hit them
put it right where you go in and out of
your chicken house door your hands go
everywhere you pick up the birds with
what your hands you pick everything up
you do is with your hands let's worry
about cleaning our hands a little bit
more and that should help what do we
tell all the kindergarten kids wash your
hands so works for us as well wash
equipment we want to make sure
equipment's clean we know that washing
equipment will help stop the spread of
disease some good dat out there one we
need to remember here's the PLT crew
showing up to spread PLT look at all the
manure on those wheels and everything
hose them off for them you know have
them stop Say Hey I want to watch that
off for you because you don't want to
bring all that manure from somebody
else's Farm on your farm remember you
just cleaned out and disinfected you
want to keep it that
way Jenny covered cell phones okay
remember this you are the front line of
the defense what happens on your farm I
can't control you're the only one that
can control your farm so you are the
ones that need to stand up and say this
is what the limits are and this is what
we're going to do and don't be afraid to
tell people hey look I know my motor's
broke but you need to put on this
equipment before you can go work on it
or if you're coming down here I want you
to do this it's your farm you set the
rules again the absolutes no backyard
Poultry Farm dedicated Footwear and
clothes no unauthorized vehicle Vehicles
visitors visitors wear protective
clothing and make sure we take care of
our dead birds properly what we would
suggest even better let's get some
signage we see a lot of that that's
going good visitor logs limit
access you know if someone doesn't need
to come on your farm like you need to
meet with a banker or something we've
been telling the bankers meet at
McDonald's or some other restaurant you
know go down at the doughnut house go
down to Dunkin' donut buy them a cup of
coffee while you sign the papers there's
no reason they have to come to the farm
other than convenience for you so maybe
it's meet somewhere else to do these
kind of
negotiations Beetle control rodent
control clean up litter wash hands wash
all your equipment if we do all this
it's going to help prevent disease not
only AI but it will help with all of our
btry diseases so it's going to be a
win-win for us if we do this if we never
get AI which I hope we don't if we do
these things it's going to help us with
other disease as well and with that
since we only have one or two visitors
and I know them pretty well we can kind
of skip through this but what I want to
say if you're visiting Farms if you
don't need to go down to the farm meet
him at the gate if your truck doesn't
need to go on the farm don't have the
truck go on the farm keep your windows
set we pick up a lot of unwanted
visitors you know passengers in our car
when we leave our windows down let's
let's make sure we don't do that some
simple things we can do to help farmers
out if you need to go to a farm just go
to the part you need to don't go to
everywhere don't go wandering
around and with that remember our goal
is to stop the spread of
disease so let's all work together on
this and let's make sure we get it done
[Music]
m